hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
i am not in my natural habitat today i'm
off uh
oh i don't know whether one would call
it a vacation it's a change of scenery
at least for me
um
i've been working hard all day as i have
been for the whole week so i'm not sure
it's most people's definition of a
vacation but at least change the scenery
um all right we have a bunch of
questions here
and uh
question here from alan
why are there still mysteries in our
knowledge of the human body in spite of
exponential advancement of our
understanding in general
look i think the main thing to
understand about biomedicine biology in
general is that
we are kind of the sole
known example of molecular scale
computing
it's like you look at
a um
we're sort of as sophisticated as
uh lots of kinds of computational
systems that we've built
you know operating systems other kinds
of things uh but
we're operating on molecular scale
and
it's
even though we can measure many kinds of
things
we don't yet really know
how to measure
uh what's going on at that kind of
molecular scale
and i think my own guess is that there
are some sort of big principles about
how biology works
that have to do with essentially uh that
have to do with things about how
computation can work at this level of
molecules that we don't yet know and
that's one of the sort of big things
that's held us back i mean it back in so
i don't know what it was uh
what is it 70 years ago now or so
the big breakthrough
big breakthrough in biology was
realizing what dna how dna worked and
the fact that dna stored this kind of
digital data of just a series of a g c
and t bits effectively that represent
the way that one makes
protein molecules etc and the way that
one puts together the things that make
up make up us as living systems before
that time people had not really had any
idea how
the specification of a living system was
given but then it became clear but now
there are sort of many things we don't
understand about sort of the general
architecture of how living processes
processes of life really happen we know
we know some level of description but we
don't know it uh we don't really
understand sort of the the we can say
things about this particular molecule
does this or this sequence of molecules
have this particular cycle of behavior
but to know
sort of at a bigger level what's going
on we don't really have a great sort of
method of description for that and i
think that's a um that's one of the
things that's made it hard to sort of
really nail uh sort of a lot of
biomedical kinds of things is for that
reason the other thing that's difficult
is
when we want to interface with us as
biological organisms well there's some
things we can do at a very large scale
you know we break a bone we can just
sort of uh put a you know some kind of
cast on the on the bone or something to
make to keep it sort of oriented in the
right direction but if we want to do
something at a much finer scale that
really plugs into the molecular scale
level at which life really works that's
a much more difficult thing and the only
real thing we've been able to do with
any serious degree of molecular success
so to speak is drugs and drugs are
themselves just molecules which tend to
be set up to just attach themselves to a
particular shape of molecule that occurs
somewhere in our bodies and then to do
uh to change the characteristics of that
molecule block its action enhance its
action whatever else
and you know so that's that's sort of
our one mechanism for doing things on a
molecular scale is just you put in these
these drug molecules and they are sort
of fit puzzle piece like with some
particular kind of molecule protein in
our bodies typically um and that uh that
sort of our mechanism for interfacing
with us as biological organisms
but that's a very
those are very sort of uh
they're not deep mechanisms for for
interfacing with us i mean in recent
times with gene editing for example we
have another sort of method of interface
which is you know change the genetic
sequence of cells just something that's
beginning to be something clinically uh
possible
but um
i think there's there's a lot more to be
understood about sort of the interface
between things that we make
technologically and things that are at
the sort of molecular scale that exists
in us as biological organisms and it's
kind of the um
we're you know as we think about
nanotechnology making things on
molecular scales that are like machines
one place where that's really important
is in making sort of machine-like things
that can interface with the kind of
molecular structure that is uh what we
have as as biological organisms so i
think those are those are some things
that and sort of the our failure to
understand sort of the the big picture
of how to describe molecular scale
computing is one of the things that's
held back progress in in biomedical
kinds of areas and similarly the
our inability you know we can have a
sensor that measures the level of some
particular some specific chemical in our
blood for example but to know kind of
what let's say for example let's say in
our immune system classic example we can
in our immune system there might be 100
billion different kinds of antibodies
and for any particular kind of let's say
virus we might develop some collection
of antibodies to that virus we can go in
and say
how many antibodies of this type out of
these hundred million pulse 100 billion
possible how many of that particular
type of antibody do we have great we can
make an assay that will measure that
particular thing but if what really
matters in the immune system is some
dynamic network of this antibody cell
effects this one affects this one we
don't have a way to measure that kind of
dynamic network of
of interactions between those cells but
that may in fact be the thing that if we
want to sort of quote understand how the
immune system is working that may be the
important thing to understand not just
how many of a particular antibody do we
have and so that's an example where if
we had sort of a real molecular scale uh
real understanding of molecular scale
computing and real sort of understanding
of how to make nano technological
devices we might have a real chance to
be able to sort of plug into that
dynamic network and understand what was
going on in it so i think that that's
it's kind of what i expect to have
happen over the next many decades
probably in the development of
biomedicine there'll probably be some
moment maybe we'll even get to it fairly
soon but there'll be a serious jump in
understanding where where there'll be
sort of a new narrative a new paradigm
for talking about molecular biological
processes just as there was a new
paradigm when the idea of
genetic information in dna uh was was
was discovered in 1953.
let's see
uh
question here from aaron
what are the approximate odds that two
people have the same fingerprint
um odds of a collision among all
fingerprints within the enumeration of
the parameter space of fingerprint
patterns
well you know
we all have somewhat unique little folds
of skin on our fingers
and the the way that those are formed is
in when one is uh
an embryo um
uh there are things are growing but the
the things that form one's fingers there
there's a folding of pieces of tissue
and those folds are then visible in what
you get in your fingers now i think i
think actually the way that our hands
form they're initially a sort of flat
plate of cells and then the cells in
between our fingers die off i mean we
would be we would have webbed hands
where not for the fact that sometime in
the development of us as embryos the the
cells that are in the in between our
fingers are programmed to die off so
that we have separated fingers and
somewhere in the process of that i'm not
exactly sure how it works
there is folding of material that then
gets sort of uh cut off and that's what
leads to our fingerprints
and we have uh lots of things have sort
of fingerprint-like patterns you know
zebras have sort of fingerprint-ish
patterns um that in their stripes and if
you look at our brains
things like the particular way in which
the the nerves from our left and right
eyes the optic nerve fibers from our
left and right eyes um sort of connect
to the visual cortex of the back of our
head again makes us sort of a zebra
stripe like pattern that is sort of a
little bit like fingerprint pattern and
we've got other things on us like our
ear pattern is also a folded pattern
inside our brain
you know brains that are typically sort
of a sheet of material and they get kind
of folded up to fit in inside a skull
and that again has a sort of folding
pattern that's a bit fingerprint like
but um the uh the details of how
fingerprints form
um seem to depend a lot on the
particular environment that you know
some particular fetus is in so for
example if you have two
uh two identical twins a reasonable
question is do they have the same
fingerprints and the answer is no
they don't although some of the features
that they have like do they have many
walls which are these kind of loop-like
things no no they're there which is a
wall i think i think those are the
loop-like things you see in your
fingerprints um do they
uh
um
you know whether you have many of those
a few of those that's genetically
determined but the particular pattern of
them is not genetically determined it
will be different between identical
twins
um
and uh
the i think the reason that um uh your
two hands have similar fingerprints it's
because they were formed actually
touching together so that that's it's
not that they were sort of separately
programmed to have that form it's that
they were actually physically attached
when those particular folds were formed
although i have to admit that doesn't
explain the folding pattern in ears
which do tend to be the same on both
sides i don't actually know how those
work
good question
um because one would think that
something sort of a complicated pattern
like that would be uh you know it would
be it's surprising that they are formed
in the same way even though they're sort
of independently formed they seem random
so to speak but they're obviously not
uh
they have the same randomness so to
speak on on the two sides
well you know when it comes to
biometrics
you know having your computer recognize
you so to speak there are a whole
variety of different things and for a
while fingerprint readers were really
pretty common um now it tends to be more
face readers and i think i think face
readers tend to be uh
quite sensitive to things like the
placement of ears and things like that
um they're it's not just uh facial
expression and even you know even if
you're wearing sunglasses it can it can
often uh correctly identify
um you versus somebody else
and usually there's a trade-off between
the possibility of a misidentification
oh there could be somebody who's
emulating you
versus uh the um uh the the possibility
that you not be recognized so to speak
um and and they're different um uh
they're sort of or the or the ease with
which the recognition happens i mean one
of the things that has been done on many
devices is to have the actual
recognition process
be local to the device so no data ever
has to be sent to a central server to do
like face recognition all that
information about the the shape of your
face is all stored locally on the device
um and that's sort of a safer way to do
it um but then
then there's sort of a limits to how
sophisticated sometimes the sort of
computation that's done to figure out
whether it's a match is and sometimes
people have very major sort of um
uh examples of that like there were a
family of credit cards that i don't know
if they were ever put into production in
the u.s i think they have been put into
production in some other countries there
were fingerprint reading credit cards
where
you would hold the credit card and you
know the the credit card when you swipe
it over something gets just a tiny
amount of electrical power from sort of
the induction effect um from uh
from the device that you're swiping it
over and the idea was to have enough
electrical power to drive a tiny
electric circuit that would be
sophisticated enough that it could pick
up enough features of your fingerprint
that it could know with reasonable
certainty that it was you that had your
finger on the credit card and so that's
an example where you because you want it
to be done with low power and with just
the tiny amount of circuitry you can fit
in a credit card you don't want the um
you don't want to go quite as
sophisticated in terms of what you're
what you're measuring but in a sense
it's just an extra piece of protection
in terms of knowing that it's really you
who has the credit card and so on
um
let's see there's a comment here
from luis about
uh fingerprints the two-dimensional
fingerprints
being reminiscent of the inversion that
happens
occurs in the body i think maybe you're
referring to the process of gastrulation
which is one of the more bizarre things
that that works in biology i mean we all
start from you know a single a single
cell and the cell starts replicating it
it starts uh doubling i think it doubles
every every few hours um initially i
think that's right um in bacteria it's
like
10-20 minutes but when we have cells
with much more dna to replicate and so
on maybe it takes a day or two to for
our cells to replicate like that in any
case what happens is one cell turns into
two
each of those cells turns into two cells
so they've got four cells and eight
cells and so on and for a while we're
just growing doubling every day or
whatever it is and the cells we that
make up the the very early us just form
this ball of cells and every cell is
just
it just splits in two and then those
cells grow and then they split in two
you get this thing it's usually called
the blastula which is the spherical blob
of cells
and one of the things that happens
is at some moment i forget how
long it takes maybe a week or something
after the the beginning um
that um you've got a decent number of
cells maybe maybe it's as much as a
million cells i'm not sure of that order
perhaps
um and it's in a big blob
and then what happens is this very
bizarre phenomenon where there is one
piece of the blob ends up sort of being
the head piece another piece ends up
being the tail piece and there's this
bizarre thing that happens where the um
the thing essentially forms itself goes
from a sphere
into a
kind of a
a shell and a taurus actually kind of a
a a donut a tube a cylinder with it with
a hole in the middle
and that happens by some of those cells
kind of getting pulled probably by
little fibers
to the other side of this sphere of
cells and they kind of get pulled
through the sphere and the spear kind of
kind of inverts itself and ends up being
this kind of tube-like thing and that
tube-like thing is what eventually will
form us
and you know one part of it forms the
head one part of it forms the the sort
of the other end of us and we we are
ultimately a tube where you know we we
eat things and they go through the
inside of us and so on and that's kind
of what that what that um uh tube turns
into
um and so that that process of
gastrulation of of going from the sphere
to the kind of tube is a very bizarre
kind of geometrical biological process
which is a critical feature of the
formation of of any of the higher
organisms so to speak and it's a feature
that presumably was discovered a couple
of billion years ago in the history of
life on earth
but it's something that sort of all
organisms go through and that all higher
organisms go through in their formation
uh okay another biology question then
we'll we'll turn to some other things uh
dzero asks is there a way to make trees
grow faster
well yeah there is um you know
we have
we humans have this thing human growth
hormone secreted by the pituitary gland
inside our brain um and that is a
is a
it's a hormone a substance that kind of
goes throughout our body
stimulating growth
and when we're when we're young so to
speak kids
there's lots of human growth hormone and
it is um uh stimulating the growth of
our cells very bizarrely um the human
growth hormone tends to be uh the gland
that produces it tends to produce pulses
of human growth hormone like once a day
or something and and so the very bizarre
thing that i think people you know you
say i'm growing and i'm growing by some
number of inches per year or whatever
turns out you grow in little jumps at
night not sort of continuously through
the day because of this this pulsator
release of human growth hormone at least
so so it's claimed
but so humans
uh have this hormone that sort of
stimulates growth of cells plants also
have that kind of thing they're called
auxins
um aux in
um and they're a type of uh they're
rather small molecules
that um
can diffuse through the tissues of a
plant and that sort of give a signal to
plant cells to divide
plants only tend to divide at a at a
particular place these things called
apical meristems which are just these
little these special cells that are the
dividing parts of plants mostly a plant
once it's formed a piece of the trunk
the trunk is just going to sit there
it's a rigid thing with cellulose cell
walls but it has a little place where
where it kind of where there is cell
division and where it adds more pieces
and maybe branches and so on and um you
can
you can get plants
to grow faster by feeding them plant
auxins and in fact the um the fact that
plants grow their shoots in the
directions they do comes about because
of the diffusion of auxins inside the
plant
um and among other other things but
that's the main effect um so yeah i
think that people who do you know tree
surgery and so on and uh i think you can
you can get trees to grow in particular
directions by injecting plant auxins in
the right places and so on so yes i
think there is a a way to do that um i
don't know whether if you kind of sort
of supercharge a plant and say grow
faster faster faster i don't know that
works very well um i i don't think um i
you know i think i think tends to be the
case that biology sort of has you know
you can pull out the stops and make a
biological system do something sort of
special but then it does it less well
than when it's doing it in its usual way
so i wouldn't be surprised that's what
would happen that you'd get the tree
would grow taller but it wouldn't be
quite as strong or some such other thing
uh okay
let's see
rbs says if there exists a machine code
for our bodies
um
is the model once working on some kind
of debugger
uh could you explain things you expect
to be predictable within a theory well
i i
no i don't really know yet
i mean really what we're trying to do
is to have a way to give an overall
description of what's happening in a
biological system in the same way that
we can say oh there's genetics and we
have a genetic code and uh you know
there's a certain operation of the of
the way that organisms form based on
that genetic code and we can say that
organisms pass sort of information from
one generation to the next through the
genetic code and so on
i think the question of sort of the the
large-scale organization of biological
system is a bit analogous to the
large-scale organization of computer
systems like you've got an operating
system and it's got you know millions
and millions of lines of code it's got
little pieces that do particular things
you know that something controls the
memory subsystem there's something that
controls the display there's something
that deals with keyboard input all those
kinds of things
those modules of the operating system
are quite analogous to the kinds of
things that we have in our biological uh
existence you know we have our heart
pumping blood around our bodies and
things you know the operating system has
uh you know something distributing uh
you know deciding what process is going
to run next and in your computer things
like this there are these definite sort
of organs in a sense where
in our physical bodies those organs tend
to be laid out spatially like you know
our heart is in one place our kidneys
are in other places etc but in the case
of a computational system a computer
system um it tends to be more that
there's a piece of code that represents
doing this thing piece of code that
represents doing that thing those pieces
of code in the memory of the computer
might happen to be laid out in different
places but that's kind of the the layout
in the memory of the computer is sort of
almost as irrelevant as the layout of
our genetic information on our genome
like the fact that the gene for eye
color is or isn't close to the gene for
foot size or something
is uh is really not relevant it seems in
the operation of of us as biological
organisms it's just they're all thrown
in all that information is thrown onto
the genome in all sorts of different
places just as it doesn't matter whether
the order of the of the source code for
your operating system puts the display
driver before the memory subsystem for
example
but this question then of of so when you
run the system and you've got your
operating system it's running it's doing
all the things it does it it has the
feature
that
well things can go wrong there can be
you know you can gradually have parts
you know you can have parts of the
system that are running just fine you
can have parts of the system that get
some kind of horrible trauma as you put
plug some crazy device into the side of
your computer and you give horrible
trauma to the device drivers
um
those kinds of things and that's i think
quite analogous to what happens in
biological systems where we can have you
know some trauma associated with some
bad thing that happens to us as
biological organisms
so i think there's quite an analogy
between sort of this organized code that
we have in an operating system and the
sort of organized structure of
biological organisms
but uh and i i think there's a piece to
that picture that isn't quite right yet
because i think that when we talk about
an operating system we have a certain
kind of organization for how the
computations work that involves so you
give an input it goes construction get
an output i think that's actually
different from the way that
uh one actually cons that that
sort of things work in molecular
computation
you know it's a funny thing when when
dna was realized to be digital
information that was 1953 that was right
around the time that the first computers
were really coming online and there was
for the first time sort of a
technological example of digital
information um i think we'll probably
understand sort of what's happening in
biological systems uh sort of about the
same time as we first begin to have
molecular computers coming online as
pieces of technology will get some
intuition for the way that
sort of computations can happen
not in this mode of there's an input
crunch crunch crunch and a single output
um but uh
i think the um
uh
this whole question about
uh okay so you're running the system and
it has all these things happen to it it
gets its traumas it does this it does
that eventually the operating system
crashes
that's kind of like it in fact when
often says of a computer it dies and
that's very similar to what's happening
in a biological organism when sort of
nothing works anymore
and then you know you can restart your
operating system from the same program
you can restart it just like you can
perhaps restart you know you can have a
cloned organism or a child organism with
sort of mixed dna but a cloned organism
with the same dna and you can imagine
restarting it from the beginning again
and then it gets to run its life again
so to speak just like when you reboot a
computer it gets to run sort of it's its
computational life again
so there's this question of well okay so
how would we debug
you know how do we debug a running
operating system it's actually pretty
hard um and it's not something that is
done that often
usually you just say look if it's really
messed up just reboot it
that's kind of a shame for for humans
because that just means well if this
generation is really messed up just let
that one die and go on to the next
generation we like to feel that we're
all unique enough that we'd like to keep
us running not just say i'm i'm kind of
giving up and just going to let the next
generation take over so to speak um
although in the end that's what has
happened in the species the history of
our species so far
um i think that the uh
the question of of what um
uh you know how do you debug something
like a biological system it's kind of
like how do you debug a running
operating system and it's kind of hard
and we don't yet know a lot about how to
do it and it's often hard to just like
if we say oh there's that piece of
memory in the operating system that
looks like it's got goofy stuff in it
let's just surgically remove it so to
speak well knowing the consequence of
that is really hard just like the
corresponding thing with biological
systems
let's see
roots is commenting so the conscious
brain is like the user code space in the
unconscious like kernel space
code
uh perhaps something like that i mean i
think that the the notable thing about
our
uh sort of
view of of what we're thinking about in
our brains is that we imagine there's
this kind of single thread of experience
you know something happened to me and
then nothing happens to me and another
thing it's not like everything is
happening and being thought at the same
time it's really a thread of thoughts a
sequential thread of thoughts and i
think the the kind of
the the sort of the unconscious parts of
the brain which we are not sort of uh
which we don't recognize are there which
we can't start talking about so to speak
are probably those lots of things that
are sort of running in parallel and
somehow there's a particular thread that
gets picked out that is the part that is
our actual experience of the sequence of
thoughts we have
let's see
um
there's a question here
comment here from paul
how far away are we from finally doing
away with physical smartphone screens
and replacing them with virtual
projected screens in front of the user
which can be made as big as small as one
one likes
you know i think the idea i sort of had
the idea at some point that you know one
should just work with the
great big screen you know the size of a
wall in front of mine i've never
actually tried doing that i almost did
that i had a set up um no a few weeks
ago
uh a place where i was for for a couple
of weeks
um
i had sort of an office set up where i
did have a very big screen i thought
maybe i would do
kind of the the zoom like thing with a
very big screen so i'd be sort of always
looking somewhere at the very big screen
i have to admit i never actually turned
it on and i kept on just using my same
old same old computer screen so i don't
actually know what the real experience
of uh sort of trying to work sort of on
a computer screen where the computer
screen is really this giant thing the
size wall i haven't tried it i really
should try it
the other technology is is virtual
reality or augmented reality glasses
virtual reality you know has
you're wearing this whole thing that is
uh blocking your whole field of view and
projecting sort of virtual image and one
of the big issues there is when you turn
your head that image has to you have to
be like seeing a different part of the
virtual scene to emulate what you would
get if you were physically turning your
head in a room
and often there's some lag there and
people like me tend to get horribly
motion sick from that
um there's a lag you know you turn your
head but the
the image hasn't quite moved fast enough
and so that really confuses your brain
and that shows up the signal that we get
in our brains is i get nauseous i get
motion sick and that's sort of the
signal the brain is saying hey there was
a there was a lag here didn't quite
match up
so
you know the technology that's probably
more interesting is augmented reality
where you're seeing through to the
outside world but you have something
projected um on on sort of your glasses
or whatever that it's giving you uh some
kind of display screen and i think
probably the most likely technology
there is something that
uh rather than that i don't know it may
work in different ways it's either some
optics on the glasses that sort of
projects an image in the right place in
your eye or possibly it's actually a
little very low power laser that
essentially
scans very quickly across
you know into your eye
essentially painting the image
line by line on your retina but either
one uh
at the back of your eye but but either
one of those is a possibility and the
result will be you know that we can sort
of see the sort of floating text in our
in our visual uh scene and there have
been many experiments on this going back
on 20 years or more um there was a big
burst of interest about 10 years ago now
people said it's almost here you know
augmented reality is almost here i think
finally we're maybe a year or two away
from having sort of a realistic
usable uh augmented reality system
and that will be uh something where one
really has the possibility maybe i don't
know if it will end up being attractive
to kind of um uh sort of uh
have that be one's display screen and i
think the you know part of the story
there
is um
uh you know you have that display screen
but then what are you typing on and you
know one difference between length of
reality and virtual reality is the
momentum reality you can still see your
fingers in virtual reality where you can
have sort of a uh you can have your a
sort of a fake version of your fingers
that comes from some sensor or camera
that's looking at your actual fingers
but in the case of augmented reality you
can see your actual fingers because you
can still see sort of the outside world
and um
uh i think um
uh that that's um
um
that's that's the uh
uh that's sort of the the next step
there i i don't really know whether it's
going to be
a um
a great thing or not i mean i i think
that you know when i first saw windows
on computer screens that was must have
been in
1979 1980
uh
visiting uh xerox park
uh a research center in california where
where
graphical user interfaces were basically
invented
and i have to say my initial reaction
was this is never gonna work
do you really want you know i have messy
piles of paper on my on my desk do i
really want an emulation of messy piles
of paper on my computer screen and there
were things like look at this wonderful
cool feature where you can drag one file
from one folder to another and it's like
really you really are going to do that
well what if one of the folders is
obscured on your screen and you can't
drag from here to there that's just
incredibly goofy you know you should be
able to move the file from this folder
to that folder even if the icons for the
folder you're moving into
happen to be obscured by some other
window you know that seems like way too
emulating the real world with messy
pieces of paper and so on well it turns
out i was wrong because it turns out
people do find it pretty intuitive to
for example move files from here to
there even though you can be in this
goofy situation that happens to me every
day
where you know the the the actual window
the part of the window that you want to
move that file to happens to be obscured
so you can't move the file you have to
move the window out of the way and then
and then move it and so the question of
what is actually intuitive to do what do
people find reasonably easy to do and
whatnot is pretty hard for me at least
to predict and i don't know uh you know
when it comes to augmented reality and
people seeing you know the the things
one will one will no doubt have very
quickly are kind of uh captioning of
things in the world like i could make
some you know funny hand motion which is
kind of my equivalent of a mouse click
and suddenly you know everything and you
know suddenly i'm walking along the
street and there's a plant there and
it'll have a little sign you know a
virtual sign in augmented reality that
says that's a uh
you know hibiscus plant or something um
the uh uh and it's like okay great um or
it might say
uh
you know
it's kind of like um
um you just pass somebody on the street
or you're approaching somebody on the
street and the thing could come up and a
little caption saying you're connected
to that person on linkedin
or you're too level connected to that
person on linkedin or something like
that
um
and you know so i think that this this
idea that sort of there'll be immediate
information about the world
uh in augmented reality it's something
that will come and i think i think it's
sort of interesting because you know i'm
sort of old enough to remember before
the web and when you would like meet a
person
and you know their name and you might
know where they worked and so on but it
was very hard to find out much about
that person whereas now you can kind of
just go search on the web and you can
quickly find all kinds of information
about many many people and certainly
more public people and i think it's
that's really a new thing when one you
know there were people i knew back in
the 1980s for example where i just
didn't really know much about them and
where today i would immediately know
tons about them um you know not because
i'm going and and uh sleuthing
particularly but just because when they
you know send me mail they put a a url
of their home page and there it would be
all the information
whereas in the past it's like well you
want to know about me
how are you going to find out you know
it's some it's like if somebody was you
know professor in some department of
some university how do you find that out
you know you you today you just go to
the website for that university and you
look it up but back in in the past it
was not such an easy thing to know it
was you'd have to maybe you'd find some
directory that was printed out and it
was old and it was this and was that you
know different kind of thing so there
was a certain lack of kind of immediate
access to to information um and uh you
know in in the future
my guess is that there'll be immediate
access to sort of uh in in sort of the
the everyday world things will get
annotated sort of in a way that beyond
what we have right now where you can go
look for the information it'll be sort
of preemptively annotated a little bit
like you know when you're driving around
with the gps things that you're
preemptively told this is such and such
a street or something
and you know exactly what consequences
that will have and how we'll then think
about
oh things like our user interfaces and
so on i don't i don't completely know i
mean i think there's some things that
have changed very little i mean
low-level programming languages for
example and the way one programs in them
has changed extremely little the
presence of the web and things like that
hasn't really changed that much
um the uh so you know i think the use of
computer systems and sort of the fact
that you can find documentation on the
web and you're not like just like i
don't know why it did that and i don't
have any way to tell other than by
calling somebody in technical support
that's changed
um
let's see i'm noting here a comment
about virtual reality search commenting
that
an mit group developed a thing for
reading your mind so you don't need to
type yeah i've been waiting for that for
45 years i've been waiting to be able to
type by thought
um
not here yet
i'd always been thinking when i was
younger i always thought well you know
if all my hair falls out at least i'll
be able to more easily attach the
electrodes to be able to type by thought
but i'm told it doesn't really make any
difference
but you know being able to pick up
signals in the in the pre-motor cortex
and the in the top of your head so to
speak where where you start developing
kind of the uh the electrical signals
that will eventually turn into the
signals that go down your nerves to make
your fingers tight you can in principle
detect that i mean maybe it takes um 0.3
seconds 3 tenths of a second to um uh to
sort of for you to decide i'm going to
press that key but probably after after
a tenth of a second there is significant
uh nerve
activity
in your brain that's saying hey i'm
probably going to type that key
i think you can still sort of stop
yourself from doing it
for another uh tenth of a second or so
so you can sort of say talk of stream of
consciousness typing you can have a very
literal stream of consciousness typing
where you're picking up what you meant
to type
at the level where you first start
developing in a sense forming the
thought
of typing that and it's like let's just
you know put out everything that is all
the thoughts i've formed even if i might
have censored that thought so to speak
before it actually came out as a thought
but yeah you can you can imagine sort of
a type by thought
type
um
mechanisms it's it's uh you know there's
one level of it where you have
electrodes on the outside of the skull
that are trying to detect what's going
on in your brain there's a much more
intrusive mechanism of you actually put
electrodes into your brain which
sometimes you might do for for reasons
for medical reasons like for dealing
with parkinson's disease or some such
other thing you might have anyway put
electrodes into your brain and then it's
a question of you know can you can you
use those to kind of read out um what
you're thinking at a more detailed level
not yet known how to do that but one can
imagine that that will eventually be
possible it will undoubtedly be the case
that one person's sort of a neuron level
thought pattern is completely different
from everybody else's neuron level
thought pattern but one can expect that
that the machine that one connects will
be able to learn what your particular
thought pattern is i mean that's
something people at least experiment
with uh you know if you if you break
your spinal cord that's what all the all
the nerves that control your your arms
and legs and so on go through your
spinal cord and in principle you can
sort of reconnect pieces of that or you
can make a an artificial thing that is
you know moving legs or whatever else
but you need to know which fiber in the
in the spinal cord is the fiber that is
supposed to go to
your you know
thumb on your left hand or some such
other thing and in principle you can
learn that by just thinking oh i'm going
to think about moving my thumb okay
great then that particular fiber will
start having activity and then you can
notice that's the that's the fiber that
activity is when it has activity when
you think about moving your thumb
um i you know i don't know i haven't
haven't been in the situation of trying
to do this i i have no idea quite how
difficult it is to form the thought of
moving your thumb without actually
having your thumb to move um and that's
that's a challenge there
um
uh
let's see
um
the uh
um
someone who is making a suggestion about
i've talked about doing some interviews
and someone is making a suggestion of ed
fredkin as an interviewee and yes i'd
love to do that but i think ed is
unfortunately
was not uh
perhaps in in um
uh
uh
not perhaps in the best condition
uh for such an interview and i i i hope
i could do that and maybe i should
should try and see that's whether he has
a a good moment
for doing that
um
let's see
uh there's a question here from d0 about
tablet pcs why didn't they take off in
the 1990s only much later
that's a good question i mean i
certainly knew tablet pcs i would say
the real thing that made
tablets take off
was the ios operating system was the
idea of a touch-based operating system
that really wasn't a thing i mean people
were trying to run operating systems
that have been developed for sort of
traditional keyboard based
guise and really i think the great
innovation of the iphone was this idea
let's just rethink how a user interface
is supposed to work based on the fact
that we're just using our finger to do
it and i think that's the key innovation
that had to happen for it to be really
interesting to have sort of a tablet
type
pc because otherwise it's just like a
bad form factor of thing where you've
got a keyboard on it and all kinds of
other things like that i think that's i
think that's the main thing i think
steve jobs is probably the main person
uh to whom to attribute that kind of
push to get um sort of a touch-based
operating system
um
at least that's my my feeling about um
um
the history there
greel is asking is typing and writing a
bottleneck and productivity um
i wonder if thought type will have a
significant effect on how much most
people get done
you know i think i type a little bit
faster i type faster than i write
certainly now my writing has gotten very
deeply atrophied i think i'm i'm um you
know i seem to practically the only
thing i do is sign my name these days in
terms of writing and the occasional
notes that i take by the way i i have to
make this is one of these little little
pictures for something i i know that um
in in celebration of the 20th
anniversary of my book a new kind of
science we're making this kind of box
set of various books including a new one
about about 20 years of a new kind of
science and one of the things that i
perhaps foolishly signed up to do was to
we're making sort of a limited edition
of this and i i foolishly signed up to
to sign and number all of the all of the
pieces of that limited edition so i
don't know my hand may be falling off by
the end of that but um uh that's that's
um uh that's something that i think is
is just now available uh to to pre-order
so i might as well give the pitch for
the boxed set of books which um uh will
be an exercise in one of my few moments
of handwriting um in these years but
yeah i think
you know
i i've sometimes thought about dictating
things on the grounds that it's faster
than typing things but i have to say i
type pretty fast
and i think that the extra kind of
control that i get from typing something
as opposed to just saying it probably uh
increases the quality of the output by
enough that it's worth it
you know it's funny thing back or a long
time ago in the in the beginning of the
1980s my very first company
i happened to happen to be physically
located where i was in los angeles where
there's lots of traffic and i would
often go there and um uh it was located
a long traffic's drive away so to speak
and and so i would be stuck in traffic
and things and i was very low tech in
those days i had a tape recorder and i
would record you know letters
correspondence you know memos things
like that
and somebody would type them out from
from the from the tapes
um and it worked okay it works okay i
haven't done it since i haven't done
kind of verbal
stuff since then now it probably helped
to have a human transcriber at that time
and and obviously we could have a human
transcriber again we have plenty of
stuff that is human transcribed but it
kind of feels like oh that's terrible
waste of time to to be talking it and
then have it separately transcribed but
maybe i should try it again maybe it
would actually be an efficient thing to
do i i tend to when i'm driving around
and i tend to be one of these people who
likes to drive themselves rather than be
driven around um i you know when i'm
like driving or something i will uh set
up you know some list of phone calls to
make and um i think i could as well be
dictating something but actually it's a
pretty good thing that i you know
there's certain kinds of phone calls
that i that i don't get around to most
of the time but then i do when i'm when
i'm driving so that's a actually a good
way to not waste that time but so this
question of whether you know if i could
if i could dictate rather than type
would that actually be productive and my
feeling is probably not
because as i say just like if i could
pick up the signals in my pre-motor area
you know 0.1 seconds earlier
you know there'd probably be a bunch of
jumbled stuff there that is and it's
much better to let it all sort of come
all the way out to my fingers and type
it and and then it's more likely to be
what i want to commit to so to speak
that's what i think at least i'm not
sure
um
not sure that's true but i think you
know the other problem with
transcription today is automated
transcription is pretty good but not
perfect enough that you can just say
here it is i don't need to read it again
off it goes so to speak
uh
paul is saying
that uh i guess for now we'll just have
to keep getting excited every time
someone comes up with yet another
smartphone with a slightly bigger screen
you know one of the questions is can you
program on a smartphone and we've done a
bunch of experiments with wolfram
language
about having a good programming
interface for a smartphone and again
it's like other redefinitions of user
interfaces that the things you need to
program a typical program on a very
small screen with all kinds of
autocompletion and so on are different
from what you need where typing is easy
and you've got a big screen and i'm not
sure that we've completely solved the
problem of doing the best you can to
program on a small screen but it needs a
bunch of new ideas programming on a
small screen just like dictating code
would need a bunch of new ideas or
speaking code needs a bunch of new ideas
you don't just if you say
you know uh
map
open bracket f comma
you know list
it quickly becomes pretty
incomprehensible to us humans and
there's no doubt a way to put sort of
add sort of fluff words in there and
things to make it so that the the spoken
code is really something that we humans
can understand just like we can
understand spoken human language
understand spoken computational language
um
this is interesting from rbs that's it i
never thought of this if someone falls
asleep in front of their computer with
the electrodes still in their heads and
starts dreaming will it type
their dreams boy that's an interesting
question
you know
i'm not sure
actually i don't know the answer that in
in um
there's a certain amount one can do with
functional mri imaging where you're
looking at uh the amount of blood flow
in different parts of the brain and
things like this to sort of tell what
you're thinking about just externally
by observing what part of the brain is
sort of activated and i don't know what
that looks like if somebody is asleep in
an fmri scanner i have a feeling that
the the dirty secret is that to really
get results from one of those fmri
scanners you have to do it sort of very
repeatedly you have to say think of an
apple think of an orange think of an
apple think of an orange
and you have to be sort of looking at
repeated
sort of trials of things rather than
just like one shot you know capture the
movie of thought so to speak but it
would be really an interesting thing and
certainly technologically not too far
away to be able to pick up you know in
in in when dreaming so to speak what
areas of the brain are being activated
and i don't even know whether the
connection to the thread of attention
that is the part that one might even
have a chance of remembering about
dreams you know that sort of single
thread of what you're paying attention
to
um whether that is the most
active electrically part of the brain or
whether that's just
something where there is some particular
part of the brain that's associated with
sort of connecting you to your kind of
thread of experience and what and what
that connects to is what you remember
but it isn't necessarily the most
electrically dramatic part of the brain
you know you could be
you know the parts of your brain that
are involved cats and dogs or something
could be very active but all you
remember is the peach or whatever
because somehow the part of your brain
that's associated with that sort of
thread of attention is connected to the
peach and there's other parts of your
brain that are catting and dogging so to
speak um uh independent of that i don't
know i'm a bad example of this because i
i typically never remember dreams and i
i am
i think i i one um you know this is one
of these uh you never know what to
conclude from medical data
kinds of observations one of the most
bizarre things i might have mentioned
this before when i got uh
covered vaccines um
starting right after i got these
vaccines
the start of right after the first one i
started remembering dreams and for
decades i've never remembered dreams and
it just seemed like such a strange thing
and it kept going for a few months and
then and then just disappeared again and
i have you know why there should be any
connection between you know you've got
lipid nanoparticles and rna vaccines and
things another thing to do with
remembering dreams and and brains i
haven't the slightest idea and maybe
it's purely coincidental and maybe it
was just a moment in my life for history
or some other medical aspect that caused
that to happen but that's why it's so
hard to conclude things often about
medical stuff it's like i have one data
point and it's really weird um but i
don't know what it means but but so i'm
usually a bad person for for having much
to say about about dreams because i
don't really remember the ones that that
i have perhaps because i am one of these
people who manages to live their life
without basically pretty much ever using
an alarm clock um and so that uh that
maybe maybe the fact that i'm not sort
of woken up in the middle of of um rem
sleep or whatever where i would be
having dreams is um is the reason i
don't remember them i don't know um i've
not really made a good scientific study
of that
um but any case that that um uh yeah
very very weird um
thing okay so serge is commenting if you
drink milk before you go to sleep you'll
know your dreams huh
okay it's an interesting claim i'm not
i'm not a big milk drinker although i am
a big milk chocolate eater so who knows
um
the uh
right i think um
um
i mean what one thing i see people uh
apparently commenting on on um
uh
um
solidifying thoughts by actually
physically writing things and so on i
think one of the things you know
memories
uh
you know the neurons in your brain the
synapses the connections between neurons
in your brain they encode memories but
probably a lot of what we remember today
is remembering things we remembered that
is rather than that original time 50
years ago 60 years ago no not 60
whenever but we're you know i don't know
when
some disgusting number of years ago when
i first learned i don't know some random
fact about some dinosaurs or something
um you know i don't know whether that
fact
is something that
the neuron the synapse that encoded that
fact back
you know
half a century ago
is still alive and well and able to to
give me that fact again i think it is
more likely that when i retrieve that
fact today i am retrieving a memory of
having remembered that fact in the past
that it's some kind of relay race type
thing where the the original memory is
being re-remembered by you and then
you're re-remembering the re-remembering
and so on and it goes and kind of jumps
like that and possibly dreaming has
something to do with this because
possibly that sort of re rehearsing
the um uh sort of replic
re-going through
the um the things that you knew before
um so you're then forming new memories
that then keep going for longer so to
speak and you know people have different
mechanisms for um
for remembering things i mean i think
that uh some people are very visual you
know they can they can remember things
uh purely visually some of them are are
much more based on the sound of things i
know i myself have
oh i don't have a strange memory but but
uh when i was a young kid i used to be
able to do the the fun trick if you look
at a page you look away and you read off
the words on the page and i'm not sure i
i didn't realize that it wasn't the case
that everybody could do that and as soon
as i realized at age five or something
that everybody couldn't do that i
quickly started losing that capability
although one of my kids has that has
something close to that capability
actually even in a much much older age
but um uh it's a it's a neat party trick
it's not clear it's useful for anything
but it's it's um uh being able to have
kind of an image-based memory where you
can just remember the image without
having kind of passed out the image as
words and so on
um
and uh
it's it's probably you know again it's a
bit related to things like
when you read
words and you learn to read do you sound
out the words or do you do sort of the
whole word thing where you're just sort
of ingesting the whole image of the word
and recognizing what the word is
and uh you know i know when i'm i'm um
uh there's sort of a question of when
you do that do you actually read the
whole word or do you just get you know
if there was some letters jumbled up in
the middle would you even notice and
often one doesn't notice i think you
know i'm i'm pretty decent at
proofreading things and i think part of
the reason for that is because i am one
of these whole word type readers and um
it it
you know i think that the the patterns
that i have for words they are specific
patterns and if the word has a different
shape in the middle it doesn't fit that
pattern and i'll notice that um in any
case i think um
uh
um
let's see
um
yeah
jion is commenting about dreams and and
um uh people who have keep dream
journals
um
and uh you know whether what you write
in your dream journal is accurate you
know i i tend to think that dreams are
not made up at the moment when you wake
up and remember them i have to believe
that there's a sort of a trace of what
happened before just because sometimes
there's too much detail in the dream
uh i have to say during my brief period
of remembering dreams one of the more
outrageous things that i discovered is
that some of my dreams were actually in
in wolfram language code and they were
actually dreams which involved the
construction of pieces of code and sort
of explaining expl you know describing
things not with words but with code so
that was a you know maybe my maybe my
brain has been has been quite
quite distorted by by really getting
deeply uh you know having having written
computational language for decades now
um and and often thinking in terms of it
so that was that was one of the sort of
more bizarre experiences in my brief
period of remembering dreams
but um i you know i think one of the
things that tends to happen is you know
and one of the reasons that dreams are
sort of uh have been viewed as important
for sort of psychological purposes
is that you know often we have lots of
kind of uh oh you couldn't say that in a
social setting type type thing so you'd
never say that you shouldn't even think
that but in your dreams you don't have
those controls set up and so the things
that well i really do think that you
know are going to come out in your
dreams in a way that they wouldn't come
out in a more sort of uh
in a more externalized setting
um
the uh um
it's uh
um
i think um
uh yeah so and again i'm not the person
to ask about dreams because i just i'm
not a person who remembers them so i
don't don't have the base of experience
of
all the sort of strange things that
happen i you know i have to say that
that um
uh i don't know whether it's a sign of a
personal personality but in the period i
was remembering a bunch of them they
were very benign i mean people often
talk about how you know conflicted
dreams seem and that didn't seem to
happen with me but but maybe that's just
because i lead too simple a life or
something i don't know
um
it's uh uh
you know prudes is commenting how can we
sometimes experience more subjective
time in a dream than has actually passed
does our brain somehow outrun the normal
computation rate that's an interesting
question i mean again i haven't i don't
know how long my dreams have lasted
in terms of yeah i suppose when one
thinks about something oh it took a day
or something like that
and even though it obviously didn't take
a day because you went to sleep for a
day
um i you know it's an interesting
question i mean what is our marker of
time
in in the awake conscious state
and how does that relate to markers of
time when we're not in that state i i
suppose it is the case probably that the
the things that are
the the markings of time
um there's a certain intrinsic sense of
time elapsing and i don't know if you
kind of are in a sort of sensory
deprivation state where you have no
external sort of impression of time
um you know
can you really tell how much time has
elapsed i i think sometimes one can and
sometimes pretty hard to tell and you
know i think there are probably sort of
externalized ways that one detects how
much time is passed even if one's
listening to you know to speech
listening to music listening to whatever
else in some sense one might be counting
the words or counting the notes and that
gives one a sense of how much time has
elapsed or you know on a larger scale
it's like you get hungry you have some
sense of how much time has elapsed or
you know the the daylight disappears and
you've got some sense of time having a
lapse but i i think without those cues
it's not obvious that we have a good way
of telling how much time has elapsed
it's interesting question what um when
we are just thinking internally our
thoughts without outside stimuli um can
we really tell how much time has elapsed
in in in thinking those thoughts
um
let's see it's a question from jeff what
do i think about molecules and
supplements that increase synaptic
plasticity and control how efficiently
how effectively two neurons communicate
um if i look for molecules to boost my
brain power yeah you know the thing
about those kinds of hacks so to speak
is
we biological organisms are pretty
complicated
and
usually the hacks you know you're
hitting things with a pretty big hammer
now
you know sometimes the big hammer is
sort of close enough to the mark
that it's going to have a good effect i
mean you know you might be i don't know
i'm not a coffee drinker but um i'm a
i'm a chocolate eater so maybe it's
somewhat the same kind of thing that you
know you're you're feeling kind of tired
oh you have uh you know that shot of
coffee so to speak it'll wake you up or
or the um or the heavily caffeinated
drink or whatever else
and you know that's a that's in a sense
a big hammer hitting your brain and yet
it does seem to have an effect that is
perhaps perhaps useful i mean you know
whether the the the great thoughts that
you think when you're in a heavily
caffeinated state are thoughts that were
sort of the right thoughts to think or
whether it was sort of you you managed
to get your brain to still be awake but
the thoughts you're thinking are really
kind of goofy um because your brain
wasn't really all there so to speak i
don't i don't know
but uh one can certainly imagine that
there are you know it's hard to tell
what which way those effects would go if
you say let's uh let's do something
where we have you know the memory potion
so to speak which lets us remember
things better i don't believe there's
any evidence that even in even in lower
organisms i don't believe there's any
evidence of any particular substances
that that help that i don't i don't know
for sure but i don't think even in the
the uh nematode worm which is the most
studied kind of organism my friend
sydney brenner was the one responsible
for suggesting that people would decode
the nematode worm and figure out how all
of its few thousand cells are put
together but it has a little nervous
system and it can learn things
and um uh you know there's a there's
sort of a question of if you feed it the
right kind of cabbage can it uh increase
its rate of learning and so on i don't
believe there are definitive results on
that i don't believe there's any known
uh sort of potion of increased memory
that exists i mean there are hacks that
are known in terms of things like space
repetition for example where you learn
something and then you sort of relearn
it again and then you sort of control
the the the the time intervals over
which you're relearning the thing and
there are ways to optimize that that are
known but that's very externalized
relative to to kind of the uh the
microscopic you know let me eat the
memory potion type thing
um it's uh you know it's worth well it's
it's um uh i i tend to think
that um
that belief about
you know the probably human memory is
fairly complicated in the way that it
works
and it's like saying for your computer
let me um
you know let me put
well
let me i don't know let me cool down my
computer to a lower temperature so that
and sometimes that does work actually
but but um uh and and sort of change the
the whole operation of its cpu and then
and then things will be different i i
kind of think that's um uh that's not
such a convincing thing
um
let's see maybe one or two more
comments questions here
um
there's a comment question from william
here
what is a memory really where does one
memory start another end what is the
boundary between the interior and
exterior of the mind
yeah interesting questions i mean
we're somewhat used to the idea that you
can write down discrete facts
that you can you know write down in
human language
i saw a bear today i saw a panda today
whatever else they're discreet sort of
facts
and we have the impression at least that
our brains are kind of remembering
discrete facts discrete events and so on
whether that's really the way it works
is not clear i mean i think that in
in the brain it is very unlikely
that one will be able to say this neuron
here is the one that remembered that
bear i saw at the zoo
it's not it doesn't work that way it'll
be some whole combination of neurons and
some whole
combination and pattern of excitation of
those things we can already see that in
artificial neural nets
and we can already see that when we when
we have a
machine learning system that has all of
these connected
uh
all of these things where we just have
numbers and the the whole result
is some arithmetic combination of all
these numbers and that arithmetic
combination ends up saying for this
particular image with this particular
arrangement of pixel values that's a cat
or that's a dog
the the way that we encode that memory
that that sort of uh knowledge of this
is a cat-like picture there's a dog-like
picture is in terms of just this whole
collection of millions billions of
individual numbers that represent the uh
the weights the uh the sort of the the
um intensity with which one neuron
affects other neurons and so on and it's
a very it's not something where you can
say that there that particular number
that's the cat number or something
that's the thing that's the little piece
of of neural circuit that represents cat
recognition that's not the way it seems
to work it's a much more distributed
thing and we can already see that with
our official neural nets and i'm sure
that's how our brains work as well so i
think that's some
and again
there is probably a level of
organization in neuroscience that is
above the level of individual synapses
and below the level of complete thoughts
as we experience them we don't know what
that intermediate level is and in fact i
don't think that way of thinking about
sort of the problem of neuroscience is
all that widely understood
but i think that is the key problem of
neurosciences is there a level of
description that is above saying what
will the individual neurons do and below
saying i thought of a cat type thing
um and uh you know it's not obvious that
there will be such a level of
description but there probably will be
and we can already see such a level of
description a bit in artificial neural
nets although perhaps not as accurately
as we would like
um
yeah i mean this whole question about
what uh
what's the boundary between um
uh
yeah okay i see a comment here from
dimitri brain does seem to have a bias
towards discrete categorization
as in alternating uh illusions etc yeah
i mean we want to make decisions
we want to decide do this or that
um we don't want to just sort of fuzz
through it
now is that the experience of all
organisms i don't know for sure
you know if we were
i don't know
you know i i would kind of think that
you know the dolphins the whales they
probably have that same kind of thought
pattern the cats the dogs it's like
you've got two mice which one are you
going to trace
the left or the right you're going to
make a decision you're going to chase
the left mouse or whatever it is
left mouse i i think immediately about
my left-handed mouse on my computer but
but uh the mouse on the left-hand side
of the of the um
uh of the wall or whatever but anyway
the the um uh
so you know a lot of organisms have this
make a decision type of thing now an
interesting question is
if you're a different kind of organism
some kind of thing that's some sort of
sea creature that's just sort of hanging
out and and ingesting um
uh
kind of um
uh
um
sort of gradually um
eating plankton or whatever else tiny
organisms in the in the oceans or
whatever you know do you have a similar
kind of decision-making tendency or do
you just sort of hang out without making
decisions i mean i think
you know when a nautilus shell for
example which is just this nice spiral
shell thing it just gradually every day
it kind of floats down and it floats up
it floats down it floats up i'm not sure
it has many decisions to make i think it
just hangs out
and it it gradually does what it does
and so
its experience of the world might be
very different i mean it might you know
when we start saying we make decisions
we have digital yes no one zero type
things it's like what on earth are you
talking about
um it's uh you know now now that
imagined conversation is very hard to
realize because
because probably if its conception of
the world involves no distinctions no
decisions
then it is uh probably you know then our
ability to kind of communicate with it
is going to be very challenging because
it's like we're a lot of what we talk
about is is has the assumption that
we're dealing with it's it's this or
that decisions distinctions and so on
and an organism that really doesn't have
that if such a thing exists
um it will be very difficult to kind of
map its sort of
things it's thinking about into the ones
that we have actually i'd never thought
of that before but it is interesting to
imagine that there might be organisms
that just never make a decision in their
lives
they just they're well you know
i would say actually plants might have
some of that that characteristic i mean
it's like it just does what it does it's
not making a decision to jump left jump
right
it's um sort of gradually growing
towards the sun or gradually doing this
or whatever um it's it's not a
decision-making kind of life
um
it's uh
uh
um
yeah it's an interesting point though
whether whether i mean it may be one of
these features of um actually it's an
interesting thought
that
uh sort of logic for example which is
one of our kind of um
that's just an interesting thought i
mean
you know what has become clear
is that
sort of our perception of space
our possibility of doing higher
mathematics these are features
of
certain assumptions that we have certain
ways that we observe the world
the fact that we believe there's a
single thread of existence a single
thread of time the fact that we have
sort of bounded computational abilities
it could be that the the concept of
logic
is a consequence of the fact that our
way of viewing the world
is a
is a making distinctions decisions way
of viewing the world and that we can
imagine an organism which doesn't have
that and so wouldn't have a logic so to
speak you know what is the logic of the
nautilus or what is the logic of the
plant
which sort of never has to make a
decision in its life
um interesting interesting question
all right last last thing here that i
need to go on i see questions about a
lot of different topics we'll
hopefully get to those next week uh
um
uh commenting that companies
into ai like tesla put a lot of emphasis
on vision over other sensory deception
sensory detection
is that also true for us as human beings
are some sense is more important yeah i
mean we can really tell that because if
you just look at the number of nerve
nerve fibers
that go into your brain from your
different sensory organs it's way
different like
the um i think the optic nerves have 10
million fibers in them the auditory
nerve i think has 50 000 fibers so
that's a big difference and you know
there's 10 million fibers versus 50 000
fibers that means vision is more
important than sound to us humans
i think you know the uh olfactory uh i
don't know how many it is for the ol
faction but it's i think it's a you know
it's it's in the few thousand range it's
not a large number similarly with taste
and with touch same kind of thing again
i don't know the numbers offhand hand
but you can yes there's a very concrete
way in which you can see which senses
are more important for informing our
brains you just look at literally the
number of nerve fibers going from our
different sensory organs to our brains
um i think that
the question of the description of the
world you know we plainly know we have a
lot more ways to describe sort of things
we see
than probably than things we hear
and then
things we taste or smell
and you know for example i know you know
we have an image identification system
that knows about around ten thousand
pictureable nouns in english
we have an auditory recognition system
that can recognize a bark from a sneeze
from whatever else and i think it only
knows about on the order of 500
different
large-scale kinds of of things
um and i think that the uh
that so that again gives an indication
of
sound is less capable actually it's
interesting question whether the ratio
is um so that the ratio for the optic
nerve that must be a factor of um
uh let's see it's a factor of 200 or
something between the optic nerve and
the auditory nerve and so in the case of
uh picturable nouns versus sort of
audibly identifiable sounds
that would be the named ones um so we're
looking there at let's see so if we said
um uh
um
let's see 10 100
wow
that almost well no i'm yeah i think
that almost works out that would be
about 50
name types of sounds
and it's surprising that that works out
i think that might even work out more or
less that the number of sort of
picturable nouns we have now it doesn't
have to be that way because by the time
we're talking about picturable nouns
we're talking about much higher level
brain function relative to just the
number of fibers giving us pixel
information from our eyes um but i think
that's um um that's that that's another
way to get an indication of sort of the
richness of our of our visual
environment versus our auditory
environment versus our taste environment
where the number of taste words we have
is you know sweet sour a few other
things like that it's surprisingly few
um
well anyway i should uh
wrap up here for for now today
and um well thanks for lots of
interesting questions
and um i look forward to doing this
again
uh next week
so thanks a lot and uh bye for now